i bought my first stock when i was 11
years old it was the first quarter of
1942
shortly after pearl harbor if it
provides me with annual cash flow
every month i get a check
even if the market goes down and i don't
have to sell
if i'm in it for number three the long
term i should make money in the future
your most valuable possession is locked
away in your brain i'm talking about
your knowledge your knowledge is
something that can be packaged into some
kind of online product want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the five
passive income ideas that can make you
thousands of dollars per month in extra
income
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with idea number
one buy stocks with warren buffett i
bought my first stock when i was 11
years old it was the first quarter of
1942
shortly after pearl harbor
i spent a hundred and fourteen dollars
and seventy five cents
three three shares 114.75
if i put that 114
into the s p 500 at that time and
reinvested the dividends
think of a figure as to what it might be
would be worth today oh man well it's
okay so i just want your audience to
think for a second okay the answer the
answer is about 400 000
so if i as a little kid had taken that
114 bucks i'd say the shuffling snore or
whatever i've done four hundred thousand
dollars today one person's lifetime
that's america
that isn't me you know it's it is the
huge tailwind the american economy gives
to any equity investor now the market's
gone down
many times during that time people have
panicked during that time headlines have
been terrible you know it looked like we
were losing the war when we first bought
it but america is a
powerful
economic machine
that since 1776 has worked and it's
going to keep working now
you don't want to buy to hold for a year
you don't want to buy with the idea that
you can sell it in two years or three
years necessarily make money you may you
could lose money that way but if you buy
it for
10 20 just keep
buying the s p 500 index and forget
about all the other nonsense that's
being sold to you because i'll guarantee
you one thing about the stuff being sold
to you it will carry bigger fees and
what i'm talking about yeah idea number
two get real estate with cash flow with
grant cardone by the way you should
emulate success
when investing and what is the warren
the oracle probably the greatest
investor of all time says number one
never don't
lose money the dlm the old down low
money number two the old man said get
you some cash flow
i think a lot of you misunderstand that
warren said invest for cash flow
he didn't say your second flow should be
investing and i'd had this conversation
with him if i had dinner with him
and number three if i could afford to
have dinner with him
i can't afford to have dinner with him
because as soon as i'd get there i'd be
like this is gonna end and that would
cause me a lot of problems
okay number three what do we say here
never depend no long term
long term you gotta be in this deal for
a long term this is what led me these
three rules by the old man warren
buffett is what led me to investing in
real estate so every monday i come to
you to advise you your family wherever
you are whether you're you got a job
right now you're making 60 70 000 bucks
a year or maybe you're making 600 grand
a year or 6 million dollars a year and
you're like how do i get out of this
thing that i'm in
and start creating other flows for
myself okay number one don't lose money
number two cash flow number three long
term be a long-term investor when i buy
a piece of property
for
four million dollars
okay
i just want to test these three criteria
captain ryan's with us real estate ryan
good to be here and i put one million
dollars down
how can i possibly lose my one million
dollars
okay i financed three million dollars by
the way the old man would like me
financing this deal long term 10 years
10 years of debt on this from a good
bank that believes in my property that's
actually a partner with me
okay i'm using the bank like i would
warren buffett's money as a partner so
when i put when i buy a four million
dollar real asset
that produces cash flow and i put one
million dollars down what has to happen
ladies and gentlemen my friends on the
instagram to youtube to facebook and the
itunes that are listening to me because
you're like stevie wonder you can't see
how do i lose my money you tell me how i
lose my money i'm buying in miami
orlando tampa houston texas a lot of job
growth i know the market that i'm
i know the market that i'm buying in
okay i have tenants in the building
how do i lose my one million dollars
because that's what we're talking about
here how would i lose one million
dollars one two if it provides cash flow
every month four percent five percent
six percent eight percent ten percent if
it provides me with annual cash flow
every month i get a check
even if the market goes down and i don't
have to sell
if i'm in it for number three the long
term i should make money in the future
it's just when when do i make money so
that's what led me so i started studying
because i love real estate i'm like i
need to buy real estate the cash flows
not
real estate
what real estate is going to cash flow
today next month
next year
and 10 years from now apartments
what do you think
since 1945
the rents in america have gone up since
world war ii
look at how many recessions we've had
between 1945 and 2000 2017
at 70 years
and rinse did this the whole time
that's a graph
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding you don't
stop you don't stop 50 you're trends
you don't stop 50-year trends okay so
it leads me down to what apartments
right
gives me apartments and it leads me at
mobile homes leaves me in storage i need
to focus on one of these because i'm a
focused person i'm not going to try to
do everything
so i started looking at apartments can i
understand apartments first thing i ever
bought was a single-family home i put a
renter in it if you know my story i put
a renter in it renter moved out i was
like oh that doesn't work sold it got
rid of it i said i'll never do that
again what did i do wrong
one door one door okay if you're taking
notes and you want to go do this
yourself i'll help you do it yourself by
the way you don't have to invest with me
okay never buy one door ever
you want to buy lots of doors the more
doors the better the more the the number
of units the most important number in
real estate the single most important
number and brandon will talk to you
about this tomorrow in any business
the most important number
is the number of in this case units
in a business it would be volume it
would be it would be it could be square
footage it's going to be huh
it would be how many times can you
multiply that unit times
and the bigger you can get that number
that's why netflix works facebook works
amazon works because these people are
trying to scale that hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here idea
number three get into crypto with
chamath pala hapatia why are you excited
about bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
well i i i mean i think
look if you go back to 18 whatever um
you know we are in a a world where
uh the dollar just fundamentally debases
naturally as you print more money like
literally by printing more
we actually make every single existing
one worth slightly less
so
you eventually in a digital economy
will have to come and reckon with that
um at the same time
the way that people deal with the
financialization of all of the things
that have happened in the economy is
that they try to hedge and the problem
with all of that is that it actually
creates very interlinked dependencies
so
it's a setup where on the one hand the
core underlying asset that people use to
price risk is you know uh it degrades in
value by you know four five six percent
in a good year and in the year like last
year fifteen twenty percent because we
printed literally so much money on the
one hand and on the other hand you have
fundamental correlated risk with
everything so if you want
some instrument of value to underpin a
digital economy it will have to be a
cryptocurrency
and the more distributed it is uh the
less manipulated it can be
um and so that's why crypto and and
frankly it's why it's why um
it's why bitcoin um and then you know if
you then move past that and say okay how
can we do functional things with all of
that then you're probably in a world of
uh d5 and ethereum and you know that
stuff idea number four sell digital
products with mark tilbury selling
digital products and was inspired by a
meeting that i had with richard branson
you know the guy that owns virgin i
discussed with richard how the world was
changing and how information was
becoming more valuable than gold what an
age to live in just think about some of
the top companies airbnb has no real
estate facebook creates no content and
netflix isn't even a tv channel the
internet has truly changed the game this
simple meeting really had a dramatic
impact on my life and my business as i
started to be more open to new online
opportunities i started selling a
digital flight simulation program we
only had to create that once and then we
can sell it hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of times passively in my sleep
it was perfect here are some ideas that
you can try create an app one of the
ones were the in-app purchases you've
probably seen a lot of youtubers
promoting raid shadow legends i mean
this would be a perfect brand deal if i
had one you can upgrade your armor in
that your weapons you name it there's an
upgrade for it for a little bit of money
and that money is going straight into
the app developers pocket because guess
what he doesn't have to go out and make
a sword he doesn't have to go out and
make a new suit of armor for you it's
just a little bit of code and he can
sell that simple line of code over and
over again and how about this not
everyone has the time to build up a
social media account so if you don't
have a lot of money but you do have a
lot of time you can create a theme page
on instagram for example and then sell
that on for a profit to whoever wants to
buy it the most important thing to
remember is your most valuable
possession is locked away in your brain
i'm talking about your knowledge your
knowledge is something that can be
packaged into some kind of online
product and sell that many many many
times over and idea number five the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is collect valuable pieces with kevin
o'leary these are the most coveted
watches in the world
i'm going to show you six watches that
when put together are the most desirable
collection you can have today
and they're not all the most expensive
watches they're just the hardest to get
and the reason i'm pointing these out in
a collection i like to throw a little
french in there
is that when you acquire these pieces
one at a time they have tremendous
after-market value
so let's start our journey off
on the right foot
we're going to be working with three
different brands now there are lots of
brands of watches and i'm not saying
these are the only three brands you're
going to be dealing with but when you
start start to talk about the pillar of
a collection you're going to have to
have watches from each of these three
number one
rolex of course
it's probably one of the best known
brands of watches in the world and there
are many pieces within the rolex family
that are extremely coveted and not the
most expensive we're going to learn
about that today number two patek
philippe now this is a very storied
swiss watch company no question about it
they talk about the heritage of the
watches there are certain pieces within
the patek philippe collection which are
extremely hard to get but very valuable
and really part of anybody's collection
even though it may take time to get
there
and lastly adi marquette you know
ap as it's affectionately known by its
fans
they have remarkable watches they
probably only make rumored about 40 000
watches a year the royal oak is the most
famous of them all and it certainly took
me a long time to get my first 57-11 10
years but it was worth the wait i'll
tell you why
let's look at the economics that's
driving this process the purchase price
of this watch
is basically thirty one thousand three
hundred and seventy three dollars and
fifty one cents yes it's a lot but is it
a good investment oh yes my friends what
are these trading for right now in the
open market
seventy two thousand two hundred and
ninety five dollars that's a hundred and
twenty three percent appreciation
yipi
yokai yay that's what i'm talking about
so you can build your collection
and you can also at the same time make
great investments the pepsi has become
desired by collectors because of its
beauty
it's got a blue and a red ceramic the
new version comes with the julian
bracelet i have modified mine to be a
red because i love that for when i'm
shooting television but the pepsi is a
gmt and very hard to get but not that
expensive
the retail price of this watch let's
look at it in some detail here let's
have a close-up of the pepsi okay here
you go it's just fun to look at this
beautiful dial
i think the red band on this looks
absolutely
spectacular no question about it and
when it comes into play and look at how
that face works so beautifully with that
blue
and red ceramic dial absolutely gorgeous
but i'll tell you what's really gorgeous
look at the value in the aftermarket of
this watch
the price at retail is 9855.
if you go to your app chrono 24 plug
this watch in
it's now last trade globally at 18
832
that's right kitties a 91
increase in value oh just a moment that
brings a tear to my eyes so we're
building our collection and in each case
getting between 40 50 60 70 80
appreciation if we're willing to wait
and that's the whole point of this
journey you have to realize that watch
collecting is a journey it is not a
destination it's going to take a very
long time to find these pieces but
just like the fish swimming in the tank
behind us you have to be at peace
collecting from the beauty on your wrist
to what they've done in your bank
account as an investment and that's what
i'm all about
i love to marry beauty
with returns
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker when you commit to a plan
of action of when and how you're going
to follow through when you write it down
you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you commit publicly to
somebody else it jumps to 95 chance from
30 something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
using affiliate programs so this is
basically where you are not creating a
new product or service you are
representing somebody else's product or
service and every time you sell it you
take a cut you get a commission for
doing it the best ones to do this with
our products and services that you
actually use as an example in making
these youtube videos if i was using a
specific phone or camera or microphone
or gear i could say hey i use this gear
myself this is what i use on a regular
basis for you guys if you want to start
your own youtube channel and you want to
use the same gear
go check out this link on amazon and
anytime i would do that i would take a
cut i get a commission for making that
sale i'm not a huge fan of affiliate
programs i don't need it i don't use it
in my business but it's a great way to
be able to add extra streams of income
without having to do a whole lot of
extra work because it fits in nicely
this is always the key it fits in nicely
with your current business if you're
trying to do affiliate marketing is
totally different than what you're
currently selling to your your customers
in this business line and then you have
another company here another company
here and you've got all these different
mini businesses that's really hard
because you're never actually focusing
on one company and you you end up doing
everything in a really mediocre way and
so the best way to do this is to have
one core business one core focus of what
you're trying to do and then all of this
can plug in so by making youtube videos
i use these products here you go boom i
could do it in the dance world right
here are the dance shoes that i use if
you want to go buy the same dance shoes
then here you go and i end up getting a
cut potentially from that it's easy
because you don't have to worry about
manufacturing you don't have to worry
about shipping you don't have to worry
about returns you don't have to worry
about customer service all you're doing
is passing along the word to say i use
these guys they're really good i think
you should too and you get a cut every
single time those deals happen
the most lucrative ones are when it's
some recurring service and then you take
an ongoing cut so it's not just a
one-time sale but it's ongoing so
email newsletters are an example i use
aweber for my email newsletters if i
sent out a affiliate code to you guys
and say hey i use aweber i've been using
for a decade you guys should use aweber
two here's an affiliate link if you
clicked on that and you sign up for
aweber anytime you made a payment which
is usually every month then i would get
a cut that's part of their program it's
like it's a cut for life not just a cut
off the first time sale and so if you
want to take affiliate marketing
seriously you want to turn that into
something that can be you know massively
revenue generated for you i would be
looking at once we get an ongoing
payment and not just the one-time fee
but more important than that is make
sure that you actually use the product
that you actually find it valuable that
you would recommend it to your mother or
your wife or your husband or your kids
to use because it is just that helpful
income
expense
asset liability so debt
falls in here
so if you let's say i'm going to buy
and everybody says i'm going to buy a
house ever since my house is an asset
that's not true
your house is a liability i don't care
if you have no debt on it or not
a house is a liability
same as if you have a car
a car is a liability
and the reason for that is as we talked
about earlier the six words that are
basics of financial education financial
intelligence
income expense asset liability
and the two other words are cash flow so
when you look at the average person they
have a job
money comes in here
they pay for their house
and the money goes to a bank
through a mortgage
so it's not an asset because the cash is
flying flowing out
so it's a liability so the definition of
liability
does it take money from your pocket and
for an asset does it put money in your
pocket
so when i have a rental property here
it puts money in my pocket
so if i live in the house it's a
liability because even i have no debt on
it
i still have taxes depreciation repairs
and upkeep insurance and all this
when i rent a property i've done a good
job buying it and structuring it every
month it sends me money so i started off
when i was 25 i had a little
one-bedroom
condo
and it put 25 bucks in my pocket
was a start
so
this was good debt
you say this the debt also went out and
paid
but it also put 25 dollars in my pocket
so net net i was making money from my
little house
so today my wife and i own six thousand
five hundred of them
and every month six thousand five
hundred
houses
put money in my pocket my my people who
live in them love paying all this
because they have a place to live
but all of this comes from debt
so we don't oh we have
a hundred percent finance here it's all
debt
so this is good debt
and what makes a good debt is the two
most important words
cash flow what most people do is they
have student loan debt
sl
and that debt is going out this way
you know it doesn't put any money in
your pocket you can say well i have a
job
well there's still you working for it so
i don't work for any of this money here
i do this job once
set the deal up
every year i add more and more and more
of it i'm borrowing money from here
it's coming here and going this way
so the debt is putting money in my
pocket
and bad debt is taking money from my
pocket
so the
the problem is if you're going to use
that you've got to be much smarter
than this person here you've got to be
very very smart that's why i took real
estate classes when i was 25
and i've never stopped taking real
estate classes
because you buy a piece of real estate
and you make a mistake
this turns into a liability
this if i'm if if i get the renter
leaves the place this goes here that
fast
and the cash flows that way
okay it's going out of my pocket
so it's nothing to do with real estate
it's nothing to do with the car that
there was student loan it has to do with
these two words here
so good debt again
is debt when i borrow for this
and it puts money in my pocket if i had
a car
and i borrowed money from it and
somebody rented for me as an uber driver
or something and i put money in my
pocket it would be an asset
my wife and i have a boat
and you know most boats lose money but
our boat makes money because it's in a
charter you know people rent my boat all
the time
so there's nothing to do whether it's a
boat student loan debt a house a car or
whatever
it has to do with these two words here
so this time i went back
actually to
1942 when i bought my first stock as an
illustration
of all the things that have happened
since 1942 we've had we've had
14 presidents seven republicans seven
democrats we've had
we've had world wars we had 911 we had
the cuban missile crisis we have
all kinds of things the best single
thing you could have done
on march 11
1942 when i bought my first stock was
just by an index fund
and and and never look at a headline
never think about stocks anymore just
like you would do if you bought a farm
you just buy the formula
let the tenant farmer run it for you and
i pointed out that if you put
ten thousand dollars in an index fund
that reinvested dividends and i paused
for a moment to let the audience try and
guess how much it amount to and it would
come to 51 million dollars now and the
only thing you had to really believe in
then
is that america would win the war and
that america would progress as it has
ever since 1776
and that american business if america
moved forward american business would
move forward you didn't have to worry
about what stock to buy you didn't have
to worry one day to get in and out you
didn't you didn't know the federal
reserve would exist whatever it might be
and uh
america works the only thing that
matters is free cash flow that's it
there is no other reason to own a stock
and
with that philosophy it brings you into
a place where you focus on a company's
ability to generate incremental cash
flow because just owning a dividend
paying stock is not good enough because
you know let's say we find a stock today
that's paying a three percent dividend
yield and tomorrow because it's forecast
for sales get cut in half the stock
drops by 50 percent now it's yielding
six percent i don't want to own that
stock either so my tests in this index
that i've you know created with ftse
russell looks at the balance sheet
every year we test to make sure that the
company is viable in its ability to
generate cash this is extremely
conservative investing this is for the
long haul these tools are not for as
you're suggesting for spicy you know
the hot stock du jour
i've done that i've been there
you know let the young legs do that i
have zero interest in that i don't care
what the hot new stock is
you know when when a company comes
public i won't own it either it's got to
prove to me over multiple years that it
can continue to generate cash before it
even fits into what i'm doing
so i'm really boring and i like it that
way we're talking about
real money here the stuff that you need
to preserve you know when i think about
my family trust
i can't afford to mess around with that
in my world you never touch your
principal you adjust your spending
habits your gifts to charities your use
of capital based on how much you can
generate from your portfolio i view my
portfolio
and my trust and my positions as a
chicken on a spit dripping cash
everything has to generate yield whether
it's a fixed income position or an
equity it has to the only reason it can
be in my world is generating capital
back to me i take that i disburse it the
family lives off that the charities i've
committed to
so i'm always looking for a company that
can help me with my problem of
generating more yield
everything that i mean i can't even
imagine buying a stock that doesn't pay
a difference why would you do that what
would be the reason you would do that i
don't get it so to me that means about
28 of the of the market
to me is just speculation a stock that
doesn't pay a dividend is a speculation
it's not an investment passive income is
the support mechanism
this is why you guys need this right
because if if you're active working and
getting money
and you don't have this
thing
ding ding healthy unhealthy
hurt unheard business stops or doesn't
stop technology gets to rest
so what you need to do is you guys you
you and your wife or you and your
husband need to sit down and figure out
hey how do we get passive income how do
we do that you could go buy a t and t
stock if you bought a t stock symbol is
t
10 years ago it was 40 i think it was 42
a share
okay today it's thirty four dollars a
share you would have lost eight dollars
but here's what you would have earned
you would
you would have earned a six percent
dividend
let's say you put ten thousand dollars
in it
this is passive income
you took the money from the active
income after taxes you invested 10 grand
you bought at t stock in 2007
2008 2009 world came to an end
the stock went from 42 to 34 i think
it's 34 bucks today
but you were paid a six percent dividend
okay six percent on ten thousand dollars
is six hundred dollars for ten years
you were paid six hundred dollars every
quarter
march
june
i think september and december you get a
check for 150 bucks every quarter every
three months they send you what's called
a dividend this is passive income you
guys with me
six percent on the 10 000 is 600 bucks a
year so watch even though the stock went
down
okay 10 years
let's say this is 10 years this is 42 or
45
and now it went down to 33 or 34
whatever the number is somewhere even
though the stock went down watch what
happened the dividend the passive
portion of the investment
paid you back
six thousand dollars
out of your 10 000.
now if you sell it today you're going to
be selling it for a third less than you
paid for it
seven grand
but you were paid back six grand
so you still made money
right now the the fact is you don't
really care about the loss
listen to what i'm saying right here you
pay ten thousand it's only worth seven
grand today
you really don't care about the loss
because you made the loss when you
bought it
the loss incurred when you bought it
what do i mean by that you took six
seven ten thousand dollars and you gave
it to an institution
it bought a piece of paper no more
valuable than this piece of paper by the
way
the piece of paper was locked away in
fact it's so valueless to you you you
can't even find that piece of paper it's
literally one little piece of paper that
says you own ten thousand dollars for
the at t stock
cross your fingers and hope pray to god
that it's gonna be all right every
quarter every three months you gotta
check
they sent you a little check 150 bucks
150 bucks 150 bucks that little check
over 10 years paid you back 6 000
okay you lost your money when you bought
the check when you bought the paper when
you bought the at t stock what do i mean
you lost the money you lost it because
you gave them money for this piece of
paper
right
what you want to do right here is you
want to stop buying things that go down
or up you want to start buying things
that stay stable and pay you a big
dividend with the hope of a big bang
what you need to do is this okay if i'm
making a hundred grand a year
oops if i make and let's take a caller
if i make a hundred thousand dollars a
year what your goal should be is hey i
need to match that with a hundred
thousand dollars worth of passive income
i want them both
ultimately what i want is more passive
income than
active income okay i'm just going to
tell you guys a little sneaky story this
year i will probably make this much
money
a month
[Music]
off passive income
the lowest taxed income i worked the
least for it okay it continues on after
i die nothing can stop it okay and i'm
not having a push and pound right
nothing can stop this so the the key
ingredients to to
passive income one you want to match
your at your active and number two you
want to invest in things that will not
not go down in value number two they
don't go down in value they stay that
means you need real things not pieces of
paper you don't want a piece of paper
you want a real asset second qualifier
the third qualifier they should never be
disrupted only invest in companies
that cannot be disrupted why did at t
stock go from 45 to 32 because it's in
telecom and it's being disrupted you
understand facebook will be disrupted
trust me youtube will be disrupted
google will be disrupted over time apple
will be disrupted there will be a time
when we don't have this phone all you
got to do is go back and watch
movies and tv shows that were made in
the 50s 60s and 70s look at all the
things in the scenes that aren't around
anymore okay that telephone that your
mama used to do the rotary it won't be
around anymore if you look at the videos
that i make most of them are evergreen
it's called evergreen content because
whether you watch it today or whether
you watch it in five years the content
is still relevant and valuable i love
creating things that are of timeless
value because it's valuable to somebody
today and it's also valuable to somebody
next year and in five years and in 10
years and 20 years you know when we're
showing clips of martin luther king or
napoleon hill the video footage may be
decades old but it's still relevant and
helpful valuable to me and to you today
and so how that helps you make money
while you sleep is you spend a lot of
time making something and it sucks when
it only lasts for a day or a week or a
month and then it shoots to zero so if
you're doing something around the trend
if you're covering the election right
now it might be really hot right now
because everybody's talking about it but
nobody's going to care once the election
is over nobody's going to look back on a
lot of the content that was created and
i hate that kind of business because i
want to make something and have it live
forever and i want people to pay
attention to it forever and so all the
work that i do
every new thing that i add into my
business
adds multiple streams for me down the
future and so it continues to build and
build and build and build and so i try
to create things that last and if you
want to make money while you sleep
having that kind of focus something that
is still relevant and valuable in 5 10
20 years is super helpful to you making
money while you sleep what do you think
most entrepreneurs do wrong
most entrepreneurs
they make money and they don't reinvest
it you know they blow it and then you
know economy is cyclical when the
business has a you know dip
and they've bought all these ferraris
cars lamborghinis and they then reinvest
and they'll
you know hit a bad spot in financial
spot so financially you weren't cashing
out you know when you started and we'll
get into when you started making good
money in real estate but you didn't
start cashing out and buying luxury
stuff right away right or no did you
kind of were you patient with it or what
was your process yeah my process was
with my investment was always reinvest
the money it's like you know buying a
cow you don't sell the cow you sell the
milk and even when you sell the milk you
take part of the profit and invested in
the second cow yeah you know and only
with that 30 of it whatever it may be
you go by you know ipad iphone whatever
you have so my mentality was always
reinvest reinvest reinvest you know
don't spend the principal reinvest the
cash flow you know and that's how i've
amassed all this real estate and i told
myself i said hey i'm going to buy a
bugatti when i can buy 10 of them cash
you know but most entrepreneurs they go
ahead and finance it and they start
taking a lot of a lot of loans in and
then when the business slows down it's
you know overwhelming and you know they
start having financial difficulty and
some of them don't survive you know but
to me is whatever your trade is make the
money invest in real estate
and be patient and every time recession
comes keep buying the thing about garage
sale that really turns me on is the
thrill of the hunt because it's the
place where you can really score a huge
box of toys for three bucks worth three
hundred how many yeah i'm gonna carry on
you
uh you're like four hundred don't need
that much
15 bucks 30 bucks like i don't know
usually
usually truly you only need about 100
bucks this could be decent
looks a little too new
but we're about to strike
they're striking to be done here
how much are the stuffed animals
50 cents good
spongebob baby
how much is this
um
all right stuffed animals continue to be
my score 50 cents a pop dumbo disney
store snuffle up i guess
bang olaf what and this one's going to
be a beast the fao schwartz fao schwartz
giraffe so we just looked it up the uh
the jeffrey
uh giraffe toys r us fao shorts combo 30
bucks
paid 50 cents i don't know what else to
say after ebay just like a quick 20
bucks just a lot of people not making 20
bucks an hour
that's just one of the things wait till
i look up the snuffle over this
thank you so much
this is pretty exciting to me vintage
lego thing never opened
uh
about 2003 jesus i'm getting old but
still 15 years old i'm excited to open
this up this was a huge score already
looked it up
paid three they wanted five paid three
uh for these spiderman skates in package
never opened as well or opened um pretty
excited about it
oh don't worry
[Music]
that's so awesome i heard
all right let's go
yeah she goes at least go around the
corner don't kill me
so good
so good
lego four zero nine eight
25 bucks give it to me
all right pay two bucks for this
all right cool so some ac snow globes in
there
and they are better than i think i
thought
you're gonna go back and play
yep
would you do ten if i bought three yeah
okay do you have a bag i do have a bag
awesome
this is [ __ ] exciting
we just bought three snow globes
for 10 bucks
and i'm fired up
i'm fired up my guy
i'm fired up all right how do you feel
feeling really good now
starting to get hot
getting some stuff now
well over the 200 range maybe a little
bit more even
feel much better
200 a lot
a whole lot when you need it
and like
it's probably more we'll see
what it says too would you take a dollar
for this sure thanks all right picked up
this scary bear for a dollar called for
real from tiger 2004 let's see what it's
worth 20 bucks all day
all day 20 bucks
who me
could i get more excited about this then
like
i get an angle oh
i get better just picked up two jerseys
for two bucks a piece
kevin durant seattle supersonic jersey
pretty rare two bucks
garnett really nice one actually
stitched celtics
two bucks each we'll see 64 bucks for
the durant i mean
and you know pay two bucks you saw my
there's a little bit of like shitty
stains on it i can clean that off
it's just crazy if i was really doing
this
i'd make a thousand a week
easy
and if you like
on just saturday yeah just working
saturday night
so
ugh
i mean
i genuinely think
goodwill
ebay buying bulk on ebay selling in ams
like i just think this is the hundred
thousand dollar a year thing for so many
people making
thirty to sixty thousand a year i feel
phenomenal this is the big final score
it's about a hundred bucks minimum
and now i know about cherish teddies now
i'm a cherished teddy's player and every
time you become more of a player of a
new thing look this is very simple spent
40 50 20
40 bucks 50 bucks easily now into the
five or six hundred dollar range of
resale i just wish so many of you would
do this it's four five six hundred bucks
every weekend it's now 11 47 so we're
four hours in
a little gas money i get it but like
net net two three four hundred bucks
every weekend and if you don't want to
be like tedious because now you gotta
post in all this cool just throw up this
huge collection of cherished teddy's 80
bucks boom quick little you know 60
bucks here it adds up when you got
groceries when you got bills when you
got college loans when you got rent
people sitting around dwelling
85 90 of this country working you know
minimum wages low incomes it just
matters teaching people how to fish flip
life it's real
[Music]
if you want to learn how to make more
money while you're sleeping check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there so in general i try
to actually stay away from these kinds
of topics because i think a lot of
people who are interested in these
things are kinda lazy are looking for
quick ways to be able to make make more
money